[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Linc and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting it's just your boys your
boys are back your boys are back of town
and by your boys I mean Rhett that's me
and Linc that's him we're gonna be
talking to each other this is a good way
we're like rappers or something it's
like we got to constantly say our boys
are back Rhett link link speaking just
this week I wanted to do that I've been
in that kind of mood lately but this is
a good one I'm excited about this
conversation because I'm a little
nervous because I might say the wrong
thing right and what will edit that I
might get upset
we don't edit stuff out but we're gonna
dip our toe into something that is
potentially controversial which we don't
always do but we're basically we're
gonna be talking about plagiarism and
inspiration what is the line between the
two and like how have we navigated that
in light of some recent events but also
I'm just like it kind of opened up this
whole world of as we think back on our
career we have all these examples of how
we've navigated this space and I'm
respected yeah and what our what our
priorities are and how we where do we
place that line in general I think this
is we're interested in having this
conversation about our creativity our
approach to creativity and how it
relates to this but maybe on other
podcasts we'll hit on other topics and
you can let us know hashtag ear biscuits
what from from a creative perspective
are you interested in hearing from us as
one of the many buckets that we can
discuss but before we get into that we
should we should bring you up to speed
on some other things that we've talked
about
you got the camera up your butthole and
yes we should talk about some things
about that and so you were gonna and
also hold that video now no but also the
tour let's talk let's bring them up to
speed on the tour for the camera but not
the tour of my anal kaenel okay by a
doctor which I will I will I will give
you more than you want to know well that
is a sec incidentally that is the
subtitle of the tour of mythicality so
we're a tour of links hanging me no it's
not but we might show some footage we
don't gonna be there we don't you don't
need to be there
even know what actually here's what we
do know about the tour the tour is we
are bringing the book of mythicality to
life in a big way this is not going to
bookstores in reading the book this is
doing a stage show in a theater with
music and we're we're putting on a show
we're pretty sure that you want to see
it's bringing the book to life but it's
also doing other things that we want to
do to connect with you in person and
there probably won't be any footage from
links : video I just that is thought
about that just now but not the more I
think about what that would look like it
just look like anybody else's car lately
go to go to tour of mythicality calm to
find out where we're going and then you
know what you risk seeing that footage
now you don't I don't have the footage I
do have pictures but tour mythicality
calm we're going across the u.s. we're
coming to a place we order your tickets
near you and if you can't make it to the
tour you can at least get the book at
book of mythicality calm available for
pre-order right now that black these
black things are the it was there some
sort of like device that pulled the two
cheeks apart he gave me some medicine in
my IV who's he just a man off this nurse
janitor a nurse okay a nurse but um so
they wheeled me into the I mean it's
like an operating room and they just you
know they put a camera up there they
searched all around how far up did he go
six feet the results were all clear did
he show it to you before he put it in
there I just gave the most important
part and you weren't even listening I'm
fine I already know you're fine okay I'm
fine totally clear they found nothing
not even a hint of anything no Dookie or
nothing my results were claimed they
found nothing
nothing no not like as panty what else
can you put up there what if I found out
that I didn't know but I was I was
because being in a drunk drugging you
think you know it if you have to chip
anything away I've activated the whole
building all that had been cleaned out
you know because I was drinking that
stuff while we were recording that
particular podcast he had an IV said I'm
gonna start the medicine that's the last
thing I remember next thing I remember I
was back here working they say don't
come back to work yeah but we were
working and I just remember talking to
you and members of the mythical crew and
I remember the look on their face was
like they were kind of smiling and then
it went some points laughing at what I
thought was just normal conversation it
wasn't that you were saying weird things
by the time you got back here it was
that you were obviously forgetting that
you had just said something so we were
like having a we were having like a
buddy system conversation about songs I
came here exactly what it was but we're
trying to lay out a plan for what we
were gonna do and I would say something
and then you would say something back to
me and you would say what I just said
like it was your idea like you're
telling me something for the first time
that anything new and I and I was like
that's exactly I just told you that
which is incidentally which is kind of
what this whole podcast is about it's
about where do ideas come from oh and if
you're they come from me I think is the
point for in your mind in my mind that
day that all the good ideas were coming
from you but I feel like I could have a
creative breakthrough we've been
thinking about things in a different way
oh but it wasn't even an idea it was
just like the plan I would be like so I
think we could divide the songs up like
this and then we could do this and we
should be you doing this with a Google
Doc and you'd be like what if we divided
the songs up like this and we did this
with the Google Doc and I was like yeah
that sounds like a great idea after a
while I just but then like I thought
your voice was my own thought an hour
and then I had to speak to him an hour
or two into that like early afternoon I
could tell that you were basically back
to normal yeah but it all throughout
that afternoon ever I was like huh I
remember eating lunch at Pollo Loco
with a deal our assistant because she
she had to drive me back right you know
and they said yourself don't go back to
work and have somebody Drive you well I
had somebody drugged me but I had her
driving back to work
but we went to Paul y'all loco first I
was gonna go to in-n-out crazy chicken I
remember calling Christie and I'm like
everything's clear I'm totally good and
I'm going to in and out she's like you
know that's gonna be greasy you don't
want to do that and I looked up and
there was a boy yo loco I remember that
that's not gonna be grease next thing I
remember is sitting down and I was
asking her asking her deal questions
that I don't know if they were
appropriate cuz I don't remember what
they were but I remember I asked her for
extra gravy gravy they don't have gravy
I got extra and they had a whole I got a
whole vat of it now I was dipping
everything in that gravy on it because
they have mashed potatoes yes and I'd
never ordered mashed potatoes in there
but I had a whole bunch of that then you
got extra gravy and it was like I was in
an alternate dimension where poyo loco
had like vats of gravy and I was I was
asking her questions cuz later I was
like a deal did I ask you like some some
probing questions probing probably the
wrong word probed I'm sorry she was like
yeah but it's okay I understand
I didn't really answer she told you that
oh I got to talk to her and see what she
asked I don't know what I asked well I
don't find out I mean I'm her what you
asked her what absorbs the fart because
you know you can feel that
like a fart packet waiting to come out
but it's not appropriate to like and
then it goes back in what you're okay
we're great we're happy you know we're
unclear all relieved I'm good to go and
you got a good story to tell out of it
well I had that story I just told ya
that was okay it was just fine right
give me my glasses but let's talk about
the recent events that is the reason
that we're doing this podcast and kind
of got us thinking about it yeah as of
the airing of this episode I think we're
we're a couple weeks we're like a couple
of weeks out from this happening so it's
it's not totally fresh but it's not
something that otherwise we would talk
about and it's not about airing any
dirty laundry or like venting about
anything to us talking about in
analyzing this thing that happened and
that was resolved and that we're cool
with it's fascinating so thank you again
it's a way into talking about a creative
process so all right so here let's get
into it
here's the highlights in most of you who
you know watch stuff on ER this is
mythical channel or just watch in
general may already know about what
happened but a couple weeks ago we
uploaded to the this is mythical channel
a video what was it called shake weight
and paint or what was the Nick was out
the title of the video shake weight and
paint and basically it featured John who
works for us who is one of our editors
who makes he's been making lately a lot
of these Cota Lee we're dead ATO's he's
done a lot of stuff with the GMM footage
that we just thought is hilarious kind
of in like the Victor Tim and Eric style
we don't know who came up with the style
originally but Tim and Eric are who we
know as the first guys that kind of did
this bad on purpose bad editing thing
yeah and the Victor thing of like zoom
in and then doing like edit pans over to
other things and like reconstituting
footage in a new juxtaposition that
makes it bizarre and funny him doing
that like with the jim bakker buckets
stuff which is some of my favorites
which i talked about the mythical
monthly newsletter it was like one of
the favorite things on the internet
right now right so John emulates that my
gosh
that's not super deluxe Oh Vic burger I
think super deluxe hired a big burger to
come in do those anyway I don't even
know if that's a pseudonym get me on
Twitter it just says Vic burger the
fourth or whatever is actually I mean he
could be made out sounds like I don't
know we'll have to look into that
maybe we'll get him onea brisket yeah
I'd love to get him here we should do
that Vic we want it we want you but
anyway so the way this it this went down
is okay we'll tell you how the the video
was conceptualized but we put this video
up honestly the two of us had not even
seen the video I saw them editing I kind
of saw Jon editing it over shoulder but
a lot of this is we're worrying about a
lot of stuff mostly buddy system right
now and so we're not looking at every
single video that's on that we're not
previewing every video that's coming out
on this as mythical we watch the stuff
when you see it a lot of times and what
we saw as a lot of people commenting on
the video first of all a lot of dislikes
it so we're like hmm okay whenever we
see a lot of dislikes were like okay
what happened what went wrong and then
we see all these these comments that are
like this is a total ripoff of dave and
ross of steve zaragoza z-- dave and ross
and i'm like oh oh we know steve yeah
he's he's been here he signed this table
he's a friend fellow creator so we're
like okay well what is this so we
immediately went and looked at Steve's
Dave and Ross character and then we see
that he I guess it started on SourceFed
nerd but then it was nuclear family I
don't know exactly how it all went down
but he had a number a lot of videos as
this character Dave and Ross which was
obviously a parody of Bob Ross which is
kind of what our thing was was a parody
of Bob Ross but it was yeah but he was
doing it in this sort of Tim and Eric
steve brule you know the steve brule
character from Tim and Eric kind of this
weird dude weird edits VHS things it
credit first of all incredibly funny
like I loved it oh yeah I wish I had
seen this before it not just because
just because it's really really funny
but then all these people are like this
is obviously a ripoff and now we did not
know we we've kind of we've been very
clear to the staff here and people who
are developing videos that we don't cop
people that we don't do things we don't
take videos and then make them exactly
the way somebody else made them it just
has a philosophy of mythical
entertainment which I think will become
more clear as we talk about more there's
other case studies that will walk you
through in terms of our own experience
with this but we so we knew that this
had to be unintentional but we wanted to
confirm confirm with everybody who was
involved in the development of the video
and what ended up happening was is the
way that our video got planned is John
have been doing these weird edits which
a style impost which is a style that has
been established by someone else so we
are he is editing in a style that is
very much inspired by somebody else but
the specific video concept was they had
made other videos with a shake weight
like we made a shake weight and bakeware
Eddie was using a shake weight to bake
and so they want to do a shake weight in
paint video no they can't they came up
with both of those at this in the same
brainstorm session right less they said
let's do things with props from good
mythical morning which we had used the
shake weigh shouldn't do in the Sports
Bra episode right and I was shakin with
the shake weights and they said all
right well let's use that prop in some
other this is mythical and one of the
ideas was to paint one yeah one almost
shake wake shake weight and bake and
with Eddie and the other was a shake
weight and paint and then that was John
Johnny oh and John wanted to do that
video and so John has been doing those
style videos with these weird edits
that's every video that he's been doing
on a Sunday has been in that and he's
done other ones too has been like that
and he was and of course we have an
obsession with Bob Ross right t-shirts
like so those three things came together
so then he impersonated Bob Ross right
but he was painting with a shake weight
and he did some very specific things he
used weird paint names he was acting he
was acting super weird
he painted some inappropriate things
that which was a complete coincidence
was none of that was scripted the way
that they did it wasn't scripted but
there were these a number of
similarities that if you had just seen
daven and then you saw that you could
come to a reasonable conclusion that we
had completely ripped off Dave and Ross
and Steve's fans felt this way
understandably well the whole SourceFed
thing happening with the SourceFed
SourceFed being changed because of the
whole brouhaha that happened with I
don't even know I don't know any of the
details I'm not gonna comment it's
unfortunate timing that SourceFed nerd
as a channel when rebranding was then
rebranded so it's like hey guys totally
new people and a totally new name but
the same channel speaking to the same
subscribers who are still around
and that does not that doesn't feel good
and about character specifically part of
that would part of that transition would
necessarily mean that any characters
that Steve had come up with while he was
at SourceFed would be owned by that
group so he can't be daven anymore so it
seemed like you could think that we're
like oh he can't be David anymore let's
do this character that's just like David
and then we'll take ownership for this
idea move it forward you could have come
to the conclusion if you just didn't
think about it if well especially if
you're a passionate fan of Steve's yeah
who then who is gonna want to take up
for him and defend him and even go on
the offensive in our comments section
you know for his sake and you know it
with that kind of recipe I think fans
you know this it's easy to believe not
the best maybe the worst it's easier to
believe the worst about someone else if
you if you feel like you're offended or
you've offended someone that you know
that you're a big fan it's also very
easy because I've done it myself to see
two things and think well I don't think
that these four or five things that
these videos have in common can be
coincidental what today is going to be
about is how that's actually something
that happens all the time is happen
within our careers countless times and
we've had to pull the plug on videos
we've had to completely change ideas
when we found out the similarities
between what we were doing and what
somebody else was doing and so it's a
it's a it's a subject that we're
incredibly sensitive to like this is
it's kind of one of the hallmarks of the
way that we conduct our business as
creators is to be very concerned about
originality and
not copying people so well and let's
well we're gonna flesh that out yeah but
but all that to say that we took it
seriously when all these people were
accusing us of plagiarism so what we did
is we took the video down not and that
was not an admission of guilt that was a
we care about this issue so much that in
order to avoid even the perception that
we would be that we would plagiarize
we're gonna take it down because it's
not worth it it's not worth people
believing that about us we reached out
to Steve Steve's a friend yeah we talked
about it we explained all this to him in
an email and then we replied because he
had commented on the video you know he
was barrage by his fans with you got to
say something and he you know he he
didn't know exactly what to believe
about it because you know we hadn't
talked about it right
and so we replied to his comment we set
the record straight publicly women in a
much more detail privately just to tell
him you know we would never we would
never do that to him yep because we're
friends we would never do that to
anybody we don't do that we don't we as
a company policy we don't uh so long
story short we're cool with Steve that's
completely been worked out the video is
down but and you know we've kind of
given our side of the story which is it
was a complete coincidence it happens
and today we're gonna talk about how
it's happened multiple times to us and
how we kind of navigate this whole space
and what our philosophy and approaches
as creators who create a lot of stuff in
a space where a lot of people are
creating a lot of other stuff but first
we're gonna take a short break to let
everybody know that they can get these
your amazing jars
ceramic mason jars now look at this
you said ceramic but you could easily
think that this is dipped in biscuit or
it's just made out of butter it's just
frozen butter nah man like you know
what's that what do you call the stuff
you make a biscuit out of Bisquick no
that flour that's what a loser makes
biscuits out of flour cornmeal that one
once you mix it up and you got dough
like that if you water down the dough I
just named pretty much every ingredient
in a biscuit that's salt flour water
yeah when you
together and you make them when you're
about to make a biscuit and you got that
biscuit dough yeah but what if you
shaped it into a jar well it probably
wouldn't hold water and these hold water
very well because they're ceramic and
they're not made out of it you just want
it look at it you just want to take a
bite out of it's got the 3-dimensional
biscuit but not take a bite out of it
that would be it's heavily advised
against because it is ceramic and unless
you're one of those people that has Piko
and have somehow built up a tolerance to
eating things made out of ceramic
material it also that idea it does look
like butter too it's like a jar made out
of butter yeah that's what kind of what
I was saying and you would sit it on top
of the biscuit yeah yeah but it won't
melt because it's ceramic but you
shouldn't eat it because it's not made
out of butter
but it is available at
rhettandlink.com/store and you can enjoy
any beverage in it it holds any beverage
that's the thing I've learned it holds
this is just water but it will hold any
beverage there are fans of steve's from
that whole situation that i don't think
we could have told them anything to
convince them no yeah in fact right now
they don't believe what we just said
there are people who will listen to what
we just said and say that's BS but if
you guys are lying and they could point
out very specific things TIG Notaro came
out a couple of weeks ago and said that
more than a couple weeks ago yeah yeah
this is couple months ago there was an
issue with a louis c.k sketch on SNL
about a birthday clown a birthday clown
being ordered by a guy just one guy so
it's like clown showing up for a party
but then it's just louis c.k sitting on
the couch yeah now turns out that TIG
has had i don't know all the facts but
for a long-standing sketch that went to
film festival isn't known as a part of
like a touring show where it's the same
concept she orders a clown to cheer up
and it's really awkward because it's
just one clown now the specifics are a
little bit different after that but her
has a happy ending
and hers is a short film that has a that
that that's sort of the the the heart of
the film is that she's lonely an ink
like it's like ten minutes
yeah but the louis c.k thing on
Sanel was a three-minute sketch maybe
maybe two and a half minutes something
like that but I mean there was there was
a big controversy over that because it
was so similar and it was it I think
just for a normal viewer it's it's just
very easy to believe that okay
then how you come up with those to it
they rip that off how could you come up
with that now what my point is you could
I mean I don't know exactly what
happened I have nothing to do with any
of this situation but I know based on
our own experience even if you look at
the thing with but the Bob Ross thing
it's like all right you get you have an
idea which for us was a shake weight and
Bob Ross and then you end up like making
comedic choices which are very
interchangeable or very comparable to
choices that another comedian male
another way to say that is if you put
with Bob Ross two comedians in us in an
environment and you give them something
to riff on you give them something to
parity and there are two people who are
of the same era in the same culture in
our comedians a lot of the jokes present
themselves are gonna yeah yes so the
same kinds of jokes present themself
when you have that initial episode I'm
the initial idea of what if a birthday
clown showed up and it was an adult who
just ordered them as if they were a
stripper yeah just one person just or
just for personal entertainment leave
the stripper part out it's like that's
just a funny thought right because
birthday clowns are funny and comedians
like to think about how to how to
subvert that or explore that and in
catch form and once we've heard about it
and well what no once once you have that
idea as a comedian and then you start
pitching ideas in your brain it's like
it very quickly gets to specific jokes I
think in terms of like okay at what
point does the clown realize that he is
has been ordered by an audience of one
and what would that clown say well turns
out I guess I'm here early they both
said they both said am i here early you
know they some of the same specific
things now when we saw that
before we got to the other the other
side of the story the or than the rest
of the story we both were like okay this
is easily could could be explained as a
complete coincidence
now TIG Notaro came out and stated that
a person who was involved in the
development of that sketch on SNL had
very clear knowledge of what she had
done had definitely seen it I don't know
that the the extent she didn't call any
names she was careful not to clot names
at least at the time I don't I'm not
exactly sure I can't I looked before we
started this and I couldn't get an
update but it turns out that there
probably is a creative connection
there's somebody involved in the
development of the SNL thing that had
clear knowledge of what she had done so
and there yeah there was there was
certainly an overlap in creative in
professional spheres and if that's the
two of them louis c.k and TIG hadn't
talked for a year and a half right well
and how involved was louie in that I
mean I don't know I don't I don't when
you go to host I don't know it's I don't
know probably more on the SNL writers
than it is Louis but but it's like we're
in we're in so such a similar circle as
Steve and I mean YouTube is it's it's a
big place but it's kind of a small place
in the same way it's like we haven't
seen him in a long time or talked to him
but the videos are floating around it's
so hard to believe that we wouldn't have
seen his character but I hadn't you know
it's like the the the guys who
conceptualized on our team had not seen
it yeah and so I can very easily and I
think when I'm in the minority and
feeling this way believe that the tig
and louis c.k things could have happened
100% independent now if even with an
even with an overlap now when she when
she says now i know of us at least one
specific person who this could go
through then all of a sudden all right
if there is a specific connection it's
just hard to it's hard to prove than
anything that happened but I'm saying
whether you can prove it or not if there
was someone who was inspired maybe they
forgot and then or I mean if if they
knew if they forgot that's unfortunate
but if they knew about her sketch
and then started pitching it as in an
SNL environment that's crossing a line
yeah that is definitely crossing a line
yeah you can't do that you can't say in
it well we're gonna take this idea I bet
a million people have come up with this
idea
I just know of Tigs but we're gonna take
it and we're gonna make some different
choices well it wasn't different enough
yeah you know and that's wrong but I
think it again it's like did you know
and what did you do with that knowledge
did you try to steer clear of it or did
you take the best parts and then make
different choices I think that's well
and that's yes so not gonna work right
so in that case because if there was
that knowledge then we think that the
line was crossed I mean both of them
were funny but and if you made the thing
I bet and you and she's put it in film
festivals and she's toured with it I
think and all of her fans she said were
barage in her with look at what they did
to you and instantly there's a
groundswell of people it makes it really
difficult to not feel taken advantage of
and ripped off you know even though it's
it's very it's it's it's crazy how these
things happen well let's talk about a
specific example with us and how we were
able to catch it before it happened so
we get off the phone song yeah so we we
have a song that's from a number of
years ago called get off the phone which
was actually well back when we were
doing a lot of sponsor music videos and
this was in partnership with Buick we've
we've had a lot of sponsors yes we
worked with buick created a song that
was it was actually anti texting and not
it wasn't even an thai texting and
driving it was just about people being
in the moment being in the moment that
was their tagline be in the moment so we
were like being a moment in a Buick well
we want to make fun of people being on
their phones everyone can relate to that
and you know we very quickly came up
with well what ended up being get off
the phone now okay but the name of our
song before that was put your phone down
and we had a chorus which was put your
phone down it was put the phone down
without your phone down put your phone
down just like that put your phone down
and then and we had conceptualized the
whole video right we we hadn't written
all of the lyrics but we had
conceptualized the jokes we write songs
in different ways but this one was we
had a chorus that was put your phone
down and then we had a few lyrics but we
had kind of mapped out where we wanted
to go we knew we wanted a coffee shop
scene yeah we were going into situations
where people were on their phones yeah I
should have been in the moment and we
were gonna take the phone and destroy it
in front of him and that was gonna be
funny right so we had a coffee shop
scene where somebody was gonna be
instead of ordering you know you've got
somebody who's on their phone and
they're supposed to be ordering when
they get to the front of the line so we
were gonna take that person's phone and
like put it in coffee we had a scene
where but we actually would know we had
a urinal scene where we were pulling up
next to it we were coming up next to
somebody and peeing on a side of it
holding up pulling out right next to a
guy flanking a dude who was at a urinal
on his phone and we were gonna sing
about this to take his phone and throw
it in the urinal and then we actually
had an idea for a whole like montage
scene set to dubstep music where we were
gonna be going around and knocking
people's phones out of their hands like
of like music violently and now you're
not going to believe what I'm about to
tell you somehow right but we've got
you're not allowed to believe it we got
this far to put this into perspective
about how coincidences can work
creatively we got that far we had that
much planned and then one of us was
looking up something on this Internet I
remember this being a couple of days
worth of work for us Oh easy
we found a song called put your phone
down it was a rap and it was by the guy
who did the wholefoods rap which you can
get you can find this song on the fog
and smog films channel on youtube put
your song real in the hole fools parking
lot we knew about this guy yeah and if
something ever sent to Whole Foods
parking lot so that was his thing that
went really big and this was his other
song which was after that put your phone
down let me tell you some things that
happen in his video first of all and we
thought it was called put your phone
down and that was the name of our song
the exact name of a from now we had
never even though we knew about the guy
and we knew his other song I've never
seen this we have never seen this with
slash Maurya there was a coffee shop
scene in which he was in line with
somebody who was waiting who
on their phone instead of ordering there
was a urinal scene in which he comes up
next to a guy who's on the phone at the
urinal and then there was a montage at
the end of the music video where two
dubstep music he was knockin people's
phones out of their hands I'm not making
this up those are that we had those
exact same three ideas including the
song title and we had never seen this
dude's video I swear on my life we had
never seen this video and we can't sound
so defensive though you know you need to
pull back because I think people don't
believe that this kind of stuff happens
and I'm saying no it's happened too many
times to us oh you come up with ideas
like if you're gonna okay so if you're
gonna do something where you talk about
people being on the phone in annoying
places and awkward places Oh coffee shop
ordering urinal I mean these are things
that people end up thinking about and
then but specifically the dubstep thing
not so weird lately undid everything we
changed the name of the song to get off
the phone we didn't change the melody we
got it well because our melody was ours
yeah the song was completely I didn't
want to have to redo that's right we
just came up with words that would fit
and we changed the get off the phone
no that why was now why would you say
now at the end of that because we had to
write because we needed another syllable
but the phone down is better yes I got
to say no I'm down that's what people
say get off the phone now sucks right
but we had to do it because of this guy
and we were mad I was mad and we took
them and we took those snotty out we
took other scenes out there's no urinal
scene there's no dubstep montage of us
knocking people's phones out we're still
very proud of what we did but then it
took us a couple of days and it didn't
work anything it didn't matter how
successful his music video was no to us
at that point it was just like first of
all we may see this guy in the whole
fullest parking lot yeah it's getting
real there we've actually never met the
guy since then but I would I don't want
to walk around almost meeting him
somewhere and then have to like be like
yeah well like explaining myself well
but out of principle if his video had
one view if this video was private and
had one view and I got the password to
his Vimeo video from my cousin it
doesn't matter how many people have seen
it because out of principle we don't do
that but the thing is is that if your
video has
been seen by a couple of thousand people
at least which this one was you know
tens of thousands maybe hundreds of
thousands you can't get away with that
we would have never done the the Dave
and Ross ripoff if we knew about it
because this not only out of principle
but also because we're not stupid you
can't do that kind of thing and get away
with it and I think that's why when
Steve's fans came after us that that
made me mad because it was like who do
you think we are you think we would do
this on purpose if I don't know people
don't know what we would do they don't
know how we feel about this that's one
of the reasons that we're doing this
part I know but that's what that's what
that was a reaction I had it's just like
you don't know how we feel about this
you don't know how this is such a
precious thing to and we think about it
all the time and doing this job for you
know we've been on YouTube 11 years you
know and this is something that we've
encountered so many times we were very
sensitive let's let's stay on the music
thing so I mean as musical comedians I
remember the first time we saw Flight of
the Conchords
there are HBO special and we had a
sinking feeling and it was like I felt I
felt nauseous like I wanted to vomit
because it was it was hilarious it was
so good it was two guys who had better
accents than us yeah being a lot funnier
than we thought
we then we could have hoped to have been
and doing a lot better music singing no
singing songs and that was the one thing
that we were really put placing our
homes in jemaine's hair and glasses kind
of looked like you and then that was
just insult to injury so then for years
whenever we would write a song a lot of
our instincts that they nailed we
because we have similar musical tastes I
mean their album was a was a parody of
seals and Crofts summer breeze which is
very specific and but I knew it because
I loved seals and Crofts you know and
but then all of a sudden now we had to
run interference on every melody we
chose well it's really what we would do
is we would be if you're playing you
know I'm playing a song on the guitar
because we would see we don't want to be
seen as a ripoff
them yeah and one a lot it so so when
you can't say well we just have the same
musical taste and trust me we were doing
this and well specifically what would
happen though is we would be singing and
when you want to get a lot of you want
to get a lot of jokes into a song a lot
of times you'll start singing like this
and start saying some things and then
when our voices got kind of low and we
got kind of like this and started moving
our heads like it would make us laugh we
would realize we're doing this because
we're fans of Flight of the Conchords
and then we would have to completely go
away from that and so I don't know if
there's any songs that I think a lot of
our songs moves the complete opposite
direction musically because we were so
sensitive about not ever seeming like
them well we also guess what people you
know recognize this musical comedy at
the time we did a lot of I think we
leaned more into doing rap music because
we were also you know fans of rap and
when you think of rap you think of a rap
battle and then when you start titling a
rap battle on the internet you title it
you put or you title anything on the
Internet at least at this point in time
you put epic in it so therefore we said
let's do an epic rap battle yeah so we
made our first epic rap battle which was
just the two of us dressed up which
incidentally just a weird little thing
is that in the epic rap battle song I
said look at this turtleneck and a
necklace you'll be wearing this next
year and then a year later Lonely Island
came out with turtleneck and chain which
was the name of their album had nothing
to do with what we did trust me they
didn't see it and it was a complete
coincidence we saw we saw fans telling
it we only eilen ripped you off is like
no no they didn't rip us off we know
they didn't represent we may know how
this works we made a fashion joke and
we're flattered that they thought the
same thing was funny 100% independently
but more because they had come up with
that before we did but specifically we
did the epic rap battle and then
literally just a couple of months later
nicepeter and epiclloyd come out with
epic rap battles of history the first
one yeah the first one was after our
epic rap battle and we talked we had
we've had both of them on the show we
had Pete on the show first and we talked
to him about it we had talked to him
about it
off mic but on mic he repeated the story
which was I knew you guys because I met
you
but I hadn't seen your epic rap battle
we came up with epic Rap Battles of
History again your your musical comedian
on YouTube you're gonna put epic in a
title with rap battle he loved rap he
added a brilliant thing that we didn't
wit was historical characters and he
deserves every they deserve every bit of
accolade that they've gotten and I don't
know if they drew any comparisons early
on or if the fans went after him but
then it got so big that thank goodness
that our epic rap battle came down first
because we would have seemed like we
wouldn't we would not have done epic rap
battle of manliness or epic rap battle
nerd versus geek our most viewed video
ever
yeah if we if our first epic rap battle
was not released before that because I
would have just felt like we couldn't
prove well our fans wouldn't have been
able to take up for us and even then
when we did epic rap battle of manliness
we had pete and lloyd make a cameo in it
because we wanted to make sure that the
viewers would know that the dudes who do
epic rap battles of history are cool
with the dudes who do epic rap battle of
manliness because technically the guys
who did epic rap battle of manliness did
epic rap battle first that's us we did
it first but it's not about who did it
first the whole point of what we're
saying is that these things happen
independently and but we're gonna and
we're gonna get into talking about
things where plenty of examples where
there there has been inspiration like
the way that we kind of approach this
like we don't crawl ever across the line
in the plagiarism but we are inspired
and our work is completely and totally
inspired by other people all the time
but these specific examples are more to
explain that there's all kinds of
examples from what we've done where
people do things we do things seems like
there seems like people are completely
ripping you off and it's but they're
100% and depend independent it's all
coincidence so here's another example of
us not realizing it that we were doing
it that we were creating something that
was converging on someone else's
property intellectual property I
remember we were sitting in in that
Mount
cabin coming up with ideas Mountain
cabinet and we were writing things on a
whiteboard and we're talk you just had
this I'm gonna give you this idea I
don't remember whose idea was it
probably mine you had recently been
probed we're talking about Show and Tell
we're like what if what if kids did
show-and-tell but it was showing yell
sigh and that just made us laugh and so
then we just we just kept going with
that we're like yeah let's let's like
give kids things to tell about but
they're talking to a camera but they're
not talking they're yelling like it's
show-and-tell with yelling from kids we
had them bring in that just seems crazy
so then we then we did it we were like
and we brought them in and we gave them
we told them to bring some of their toys
so they brought some toys they could
legitimately do show-and-tell
about showing yell and we set up this
whole thing we were like okay we want
the kids to feel like they're talking to
the audience directly we really thought
that it was important that the audience
member felt like the kids were just
staring right into their stole and
yelling at them about their favorite
teddy bear or whatever the case we did
the whole Errol Morris thing right which
we didn't know existed Ben told us that
it exists yeah it was a technique that
we thought we invented because we wanted
people to look into the camera but we
wanted to be able to give them
directions so we set up a teleprompter
which had we were being shot video of us
as the director was being shot and put
on a teleprompter in front of a camera
filming a kid so that the kid could look
straight into the lens but there was the
screen in front of them would be our
face was be our faces so whenever we
would give direction like okay Roger
tell me about your teddy bear he would
look at me and and I would like nod my
head and like give a response and we
were in a different room a kid can't
look at a camera and give you know
giving natural the kid will look
naturally to the person who's talking so
we had the person talking in the camera
basically and we went to a different
room so we had hours of conversations
with Ben about how to pull this off and
he came up with the teleprompter thing
and we worked it all out and we were
really excited about this technical
thing that we invented which we didn't
and
do this thing well that's really
original because what we're finding is
that even in telling the stories which
this isn't even what the story's about
you find out that you independently came
up with something because errol morris
great documentary in documentarian
vernon florida is a great documentary
that you should watch that he made but
he kind of created this technique of
interviewing people so people would be
looking at the camera and we didn't even
realize that we had independently
replicated the technique and done it for
these kids but that's not even what the
story's about and we had cast all these
kids we had to bring him in and we had
our friends bring their kids in and they
were all excited about being in a rhett
and Link video and then we're like we
get all this footage we also but we also
gave them but besides them bringing
their toys in we gave them old
technology like old phones stuff they
would not have a clue what it was
because calculators I'm talking about
things they didn't have a clue what it
was would be very funny and then and
hopefully we be right that if they were
yelling it wouldn't be annoying and
that's a big question why oh and write
about the whole thing and while we were
in the process if we were in
post-production we had we had filmed
these kids for two days straight like
10-hour days we were sitting there in
the in the Edit Bay putting the stuff
together and we happen to see that the
fine brothers good friends of ours had
released on there it wasn't even a react
channel at the time it may have just
been fine brothers before they came out
with a react channel I can't remember
they had kids react on their channel so
they did have kids but they had
specifically they had moved to a place
where instead of kids reacting to videos
kids were reacting to things that they
were being handed in it was specifically
old technology like old phones and stuff
like that and we were like you know what
we have to scrap this entire project
call the parents tell them that we're
not gonna do use the footage we're sorry
we paid them whatever appearance fee
that we had given them but that was it
we owned the footage we still have it
but we've never released it because we
found out that the fine brothers did
something that it wasn't showing yell
that kids weren't yelling the kids but
the kids were looking we were like if
we're gonna expand this series and do
the things that we want to do with it
and then go into the natural places that
we would want to go it's going to very
quickly become this very this
that is comparable to kids react and we
can't do that because we don't do that
by no means even if they weren't friends
of ours right yeah yeah but especially
because they were and you might say well
then hi sighs like guys you were so
close to that you're talking about doing
videos with kids reacting to something
you hand him well first of all we didn't
look at it that way we didn't realize
that at the time that's how I can say it
now and how I realize a viewer would see
it but it was like okay they had kids
reacting to videos period that was it
they hadn't placed anything in their
hand and they didn't have them talking
directly to the audience but again you
know no but they did that's that's
specifically what I just said that not
what that's when we conceptualized our
idea oh that didn't exist when we
conceptualize the I we had all the stuff
in the can and then they release that
and it was just like what we didn't
realize is that a natural expansion of
kids reacting to videos is very stuff
it's kids reacting this stuff that you
would hand them and then what's the
first thing you're gonna hand them they
hand it in the same stuff we did because
they're smart like a Walkman producers
yeah they handed them the same stuff and
it's not because they got the idea we
were like they got into our Google Doc
or we got into their Google Doc it's
just because when she wants you you put
people in it's kind of like when
somebody has a concussion it's like the
the old story that we've told a million
times about links concussion in college
when he when he hit his head anymore the
colonoscopy I guess so
I've told the story a million times and
we and I tell the story in detail in our
book book of mythicality calm available
for pre-order don't make it sexy wait no
I when I'm I sell something I make it
sexy because sex sells man so make it
sexy it's kind of so you said I make it
look sick hold on I'm just coming to
evidently I hurt my left hip and you
said it a hundred times that night which
is a very specific phrase but it was
because you were put in the same
situation you were constantly coming to
and you were trying to figure and so
your brain resets and says the exact
same thing you put a comedian or a
producer or somebody's in the same
environment and who's constantly trying
to make Internet videos that people like
you put them in the same scenario you
tell them to come up with an idea that
seong something they're going to come up
with similar things and that's why we've
gotten to a point where now we don't go
through the trouble of bringing a bunch
of kids in and filming something we
don't make the video we don't write the
song we don't come up with a melody as
soon as we have an idea we go on this
google dive and sometimes we get very
and sometimes it's hard to do it cuz you
get super excited about the idea and you
want to moot you want to develop the
idea and you want to move it along but
you've got to stop you got to google it
you got to see if it's been done before
you got to see if it's something's been
done that's like it and then once you
see it you have to make a decision how
are we going are we going to scrap this
are we gonna change this like how are we
going to react which I think GMM is a
perfect yeah it's a perfect is we run
the stuff through this all the time
having over a thousand episodes of GMM
we have to answer this question all the
time yeah there's so many videos and you
know and a lot of them we're not even
developing videos but we're developing
formats and then we you know we're not
talking about what other people have
done I you know I do feel like we
developed formats on GMM and then they
show up in other places all the time the
knee-jerk reaction is to take it
personally or to see it as rip off that
sometimes that could be the case
sometimes it's not but it's like we
can't control what other people do know
but so again we're still focusing on
what what we do and what our approach is
I think at this point but I mean there
was it it was an example just a few
hours ago we were talking about um a GMM
episode called food court you know we do
so much food-related stuff and it's like
alright we're gonna let's develop
something with three people either three
guest hosts or the two of us and another
another person because food food court
is a thing in the mall and a court is
the thing where you've got a judge and
then you got two lawyers it says Micah
said it when Micah said food court I was
like I don't even know with a specific
idea but I love it already because I can
see exactly where you're going with this
and then we get excited about it in
about three minutes into this exciting
conversation Eddy says tastemade did it
taste
they did it already food court here it
is and we're sin it's like you talked
about like pricking the balloon cuz it's
hard to come up with ideas it's hard to
come up with good ideas I wanted to kill
Eddie right then it was like it's like
why do I want to kill Eddie Eddie Eddie
not only the messenger thank goodness
he's bringing this up because we were so
emotional so we would have gone another
half hour we would have developed the
whole episode we've developed the
creative and then he would have found it
but in that moment you know you since
that frustration it's like don't tell me
that well and so okay and so this is
what how we decided to proceed we bring
the videos up we watch them and we see
that okay well this is actually a little
bit more like our old series to bethe
Rama where they were debating the you
know debating between two foods and it's
also scripted so it's more of a sketch
thing they haven't they haven't done it
in a year not that it matters how old it
is but it's like okay well we want to do
something they're not it's not a current
in production series that will that is
direct competitor but that doesn't
really matter because it's out there and
like we said at a principle we don't
copy people I thought we came up with
the idea independently and so we were
like okay but but if it the only reason
I said if this if it's happening right
now is that I might just back away
totally but it's like okay this is not
an active property it seems like he
didn't work out for them right because
I'm let's continue the conversation
because we have to be answer the
question do you shut it down right and
or do you change it and if you change it
how do you change it so the way that
when we haven't fully developed the idea
but we were like you know the thing that
we really like about this idea is that
there are already people not our idea so
yeah just to clarify not what we like
about their idea but what we like about
our idea that wasn't their idea that
they had independent and what we like
about our idea is the fact that it's
three people something that we can do
with a guest it is food related which we
know that people love food related
videos and we love the idea of two
people having to make a case about some
kind of food but wouldn't it would
involves people having to eat it the
consequence is the the winner of the
argument doesn't have to eat the judge
eats it and the loser has to eat their
own thing and that was in s Kumar's
can tell that's and that's completely
different than their ID totally
different their ideas it's just a debate
there's no eating it's a sketch it's
scripted whatever so we have decided to
move forward we don't know when the idea
is gonna so then I'm like but we can't
call it food court which is an amazing
idea we can't we can't call it that so
why not judge foodie I know so it's like
I mean I don't know what we're gonna
call it but that's like the working idea
now and this is fresh that literally
happened
right before we came in here we were
having that that brainstorming meeting
and if the and if this comes out on the
internet before we make it and someone
does judge foodie I swear I'm coming
after ya well we have agents for that
kind of thing you know steel it will be
so ironic I know you think it's funny
agents still the thing that we talked
about in the podcast about not stealing
people's stuff don't you do it yeah
don't you do it we actually won't send
anybody to kill you we wouldn't do that
either I just said agent of death bring
you to us to kill you really just kind
of just I was just being sensational I
don't think anybody should die because
of it but I mean Roy and guava juice
having tremendous success with doing
lots of things that we are akin to
things that we do on good mythical
morning and this is yeah this is a very
weird thing how this came down so it's
like we want to you know there's well
there's the bad thing which I'll get to
but then there's a okay it's like we
want to do something on fidget toys and
then well we're literally we had the
whole thing planned so then we planned
the whole thing about what we want to do
but then we look we just search fidget
toys and we see what's out there it was
like we had planned what we were gonna
do and then like two days before we were
gonna shoot our fidget toys episode yeah
we had ordered and acquired
like we literally had all of our fidget
toys he came out with his fidget toys
video which was kind of a typical guava
juice video where he's just kind of
being crazy with a bunch of fidget toys
on his second channel and we were like
well that's kind of what we were gonna
do I mean course with totally different
style than what Roy does but similar in
a lot of ways and that we're gonna be
what's the rhett and Link take on fidget
toys so what we decided to do because we
had planned the whole thing we're like
well lots of people are talking about
fidget toys they're kind of in the news
we're going to talk about fidget toys
we're gonna play with fidget toys we're
going to
with different fidget toys that he
played with and then our angle is gonna
be how we think that there's like a poor
man's everyday version of a fidget toy
so like you would hold up something that
was a real fidget toy and I would be
like what about this like you had the
thing with all the little buttons on it
I held up a universal remote and I was
like I think this is good so that was
our comedic angle it was let me move
forward there was a comedic take but
there was also a scientific take which
allowed us to title the video our fidget
toys bad for you or whatever we called
it right so we wanted to have a
legitimate scientific conversation about
it because that's what people cared
illegitimate science is what we're all
about link I'm gonna have a legitimate
conversation about science which may or
may not have been accurate but the bad
thing is even more interesting so back
in the day when Roy and Alex were
together as the wasabi brothers before
they were doing their things
independently they did an ice-bath
challenge now I don't think that they
were the first people to do an ice-bath
challenge and a lot of people have done
ice bath challenges since but this is
the challenge whole area genre of
YouTube is a little bit different
because the whole idea of like an ice
bucket challenge mm-hm or the baby food
challenge is that well it's not anybody
everybody's supposed to do it when you
come up with that idea the expectation
is that millions of people will end up
doing this idea and so we like to get in
on those challenge videos but we'd like
to do our little spin on them right well
we require that of ourselves it's not
just that we like to do it it's like we
never want to just seem like we're doing
we're jumping on a bandwagon right we
always go to great links to from a
production standpoint a planning
standpoint and a comedy standpoint do do
it on our own terms so that it feels
different yeah so with that one in
particular we had like we talked again
we talked about the science behind it a
little bit like what the actual purpose
of this was and then we got ridiculous
and we sang the frozen song and then you
found the sprite and we did all the sort
of the comedic beats that we wanted to
do but then not too long after that we
had the idea for us to bathe in cereal
during one of our back-up plan Geico
videos when we were at the cereal
factory and so we had this giant cereal
bowl created this is the inspiration for
the cover of the book of mythicality
available at book of mythicality
for pre-order and make it look sexy so
but that's where that whole thing comes
from and so we started taking baths and
weird things like the cereal and then
ranch dressing and chicken noodle soup
at the same time Roy had bathing and all
types joy and Alex had decided they were
going to do their own things and so they
each have their own Channel and now
Roy's got guava juice and they both
continue to do bath challenges beyond
ice and now Roy is bathing in something
every week or so it seems like I always
see him in a different bathtub he's so
clean and so now it's got this like well
you guys did the ice bath challenge when
you were together we did it kind of did
our own take on it now we're bathing
another stuff but now you're bathing and
stuff and you're doing it a whole lot
more now people on YouTube would
associate you with weird bathtubs filled
with things and so now if you bathe then
something we can't bathe in it and your
bathing and things all the time
it just this is the world that this is
the world that we live in mean it's
frustrating
like we're not mad at Roy by any means
but it's like he found something that's
working and he's doing it but in the in
the strictest definition of frustration
when you're plans are thwarted or made
more difficult it's it's it's our own
creative problem with the parameters
that we put up this like alright maybe
we're not gonna get in tubs as much and
we thought and we haven't because of
that but maybe we can make a human nacho
Noble here as long as Roy hadn't done it
like that it it matters that much to us
that like we have to do things that are
different or we and we have to do them
on our own terms and even with all that
said we're still going to end up doing
things that something falls through the
cracks we'd you know somebody releases
something a lot of times it happens with
BuzzFeed well there they will release
something between the time that we've
planned and shot something because we
shoot things ahead of time at times when
we have to based on our schedule and
sometimes we've got something completely
edited and ready to go and then BuzzFeed
will do something
that's so much like what we've come up
with that we just have to be like well
we can't we don't have time to replace
that we've we've just got to throw it
out there and I hate it if it seems like
okay
BuzzFeed much it's like you know that
those commoners who don't understand how
much we care about this and that it was
just a coincidence that
we both had this idea and it came out
within days of each other but we were on
the wrong side of that those days and
the thing is is that because there are a
lot of people out there we're not going
to name specific names there are a lot
of organizations and companies out there
and some people who don't approach this
in a way that we do and if they see
something that works they just take it
and they do it exactly the same way they
may have a slightly different voice but
they do videos that are titled in
exactly the same way that you know
you've got I see this all the time
you've got BuzzFeed has the worth it
series so it's like $500 PI versus $5 PI
or whatever the whatever the different
things are and then you see that that
has become a genre of video that now
lots of people do this amount of thing
this dollar amount versus this dollar
amount it might be somebody who's like
I'm gonna do a tech version of that or
I'm gonna do this version of that but
we're not going to do that we don't do
that as a principle it happens
accidentally sometimes but because there
are so many people out there who are
willing to do it and just see it as this
is how the internet works you just take
inspiration because that exists is
natural for us to then be accused of
that if we do something that appears
that way and it's gonna happen because
we make so much content and we're people
we're people man we're not we're not an
organization that the accountability
kind of gets lost you know it's like
people start hating on in comments on an
organization that makes videos companies
can get away with well even if they
don't get away with it just by the the
sheer quantity of the work that's coming
out it gets lost in the mix and we take
it personally like the whole well
because we're people yeah but we may not
have been involved in the development of
that specific video on this as mythical
because this is how we run our business
we can't we can't be involved in every
single thing and this is mythical as
something that we kind of guide it and
offer create a direction for we're not
involved in every detail but when that
accusation is levied at us we take it
personally because well ultimately we
are personally responsible and people's
and this is mythical is us I mean
ultimately mythical entertainment is us
and the buck stops with us and
so that's why we do take it seriously
and if all of a sudden people think Oh
Rhett Rhett & link are after that now
huh Rhett link of rhettandlink are
willing to copy now that's where they're
going we're just like no you don't
understand this is this means a lot to
us and there's many creators that we've
talked to well I take that back
I believe that there are many creators
out there and we've talked to a handful
of them that we know share our
conviction and that they take it very
seriously but the thing that the place
that the conversation goes is that that
that doesn't make it easy it's a
difficult thing and when you're pumping
out a whole lot of videos boy it gets
difficult that's showing y'all thing
blindsided us and that was a difficult
thing to like well it takes oh I'm so
glad we did I mean it was like it was
just it was our own fault we should have
caught that a lot earlier I think that's
ultimately you know what we try to do in
terms of our habits yeah well and let's
talk a little bit about buddy system
because yeah this is haven't you got
likes scripting things conceptualizing
stuff it's a totally different world but
all the same stuff applies and the risk
in doing something like buddy system is
so much greater right because we're
developing season two right now and the
creative is pretty much locked into
place but you know we're coming up with
specific dialogue and that kind of thing
but we're gonna shoot that and then it's
gonna take months to edit I don't know
exactly when it's gonna come out but
between right now and the time the buddy
system goes live but he says some season
two goes live any one of the jokes that
we come up with in this time frame could
be done somebody could come up with the
exact same idea for what our season is
or whatever and we're screwed you can't
reshoot any of that and then you just
have to be like you know what guys I'm
sorry that this joke ended up being the
same that's one thing that's we're
scripted because it moves more slowly is
really interesting yeah when I look at
Flixter I was looking I always look on
reviews after I watch a movie to see if
my opinions right yeah well I just look
at him see what I'm supposed to say it
about if everyone else's opinion is
right and you can go down to upcoming
movies and like scroll to like what's
coming out in the future and you know
you get to a certain point when it's
like 2018 and the only thing on there's
like
avatar two three four five and six oh no
we've already planned avatar two three
four five and six as well and it's on
yes no but I scroll all the way to the
bottom and there's a bureau of
otherworldly or something it's Bo oh I
don't know what the third oh stands for
but it's ghostbusters starring Seth
Rogen and somebody else and it was gonna
come out at the same time as
Ghostbusters with Kristen Wiig yeah
around the same time and then they
shelved it for awhile I was like dang
y'all need to take this thing off
Flixter cuz it looks like it's hanging
out there forever and it I just I don't
know I have no clue what the story is
but I just infer that it's one of those
situations where it's like oh man we
were working on our ghost movie but then
it got shelved for like two years
because of somebody else's going we
can't we can't it aren't our sighs
company we can't afford that I think I
think if we make something it's like oh
crap this is going out guys sorry so our
goal and I think we've succeeded is to
make buddy system as we talked about so
out of left field and every choice be
the unexpected choice from a
foundational level and how these how its
structured how episodes work how the
whole series works but that doesn't mean
that it would ensure it's an insurance
policy against it seem like we're biting
anybody yeah anybody else's ideas but I
don't want to say night we kind of
waited a while to get into this because
I but get into the honest truth is that
we're not saying that we're not inspired
by people know you know and specifically
I think about buddy system season one
and we were watching
we had been introduced to the Mighty
Boosh just a couple of months before we
started writing season one of but
because people said that our sketch
Tober video the puzzle where we started
singing impromptu crimping crit was
crimping which is what they called the
thing that the Mighty Boosh does when
they start singing a song like it's an
inside joke acapella and we had never
seen the Mighty Boosh and but we were
doing the exact same thing and people
were like oh so you know and people
didn't say that we were biting them
people were like oh it's cool you guys
are crimping you guys are doing what the
Mighty Boosh does and we're like oh he's
a Mighty Boosh then we watch their stuff
which if you have not watched it it's
all available on Amazon and probably
other places
it's a
incredible British comedy two guys
musical comedy is so weird
in a wonderful way we absolutely love it
you should watch it do yourself a favor
and watch it we started well we once we
started going down that rabbit hole we
couldn't resist watching the whole thing
like watching it with my boys because
there's a bunch of balls jokes and I
need the balls jokes there kids love
that there's like mirror ball testicles
yeah one scene Oh Greg right pretty
amazing well no that's different that's
what man I can't remember then there's
the old Greg scene where he's a guru
type creature ol greg has a light that
emits from his crotch and it really emit
their very crotch centric but there's a
couple of things that help a lot of them
from buddies I need me think about this
until right now but you know how the
light comes out of my mouth and goes
into your mouth during that scene in the
second episode of buddy system season 1
yeah that hole light thing and I'm in
the robe you know i that that was that
permeated into our minds through the
whole whole greg thing yeah and it and
then we realized it later and we were
like cuz we conceptualize it that the
light comes from your mouth into my
mouth and then it comes out of your
crumbs out of my crotch and goes into
your crotch it was gonna be a big circle
yeah like they were like you know what I
think we can do without the crotch first
of all it's it's uh it's it doesn't make
a lot of sense
second of all like it's twice as
expensive from a from an effect
standpoint if we just go from mouth to
mouth it's it's half as expensive and
it's in it in it there's a lot of light
that comes from crotch in mighty boosh
so we shouldn't rush it and wear that on
our sleeve I mean there's it it starts
to seem like we're doing something
specific but then in episode the episode
the soul-searching episode episode 6 of
season 1 I think it is there's the scene
where I run into your character Peter
who is a dude that lives out in the
wilderness and wears only dark shorts
tortes and we have this weird
interaction and you only want to dance
with me it's one of my favorite scenes
of the whole series and that guy is
heavily inspired not directly but now
looking back on it I know indirectly by
old Greg because the whole old Greg
scene in the mighty boosh he meets this
weird dude who kind of wants to connect
with him in a weird way almost a
romantic way
and he's just strange and you can't
really explain why he is where he is and
why he wants to be who he is and so we
had a similar exchange where you wanted
to dance with me and you're trying to
find all these ways and your name is
Peter and you insist on it being though
it's Peter Peter with a D Peter not
Peter Peter and all that is the same
kind of humor that they do in the mighty
boosh and I don't see that as plagiarism
at all I see that as inspiration
so I'm by no means am i saying that
we're not inspired by other people all
the time but it is a little bit of a
dangerous thing to be watching something
while you're writing something else
which is interesting
Sturgill Simpson talked about how when
he listened to Jason is Bulls album
southeastern he listened to the first
song and he said and he stopped and he
said I'm not gonna listen to any more of
this because it's so good I'm gonna be
overly influenced by it and he didn't
even listen to Jason's last album
because he's like he's too good so
they're friends and he hasn't even
listened to his albums because he
doesn't want to be influenced by them so
some people are so protective of that
one that they want to be original that
they don't even listen to another artist
when they're writing an album yeah I
think I think that's just a byproduct of
I think that's a coincidental benefit of
how limited I am and the stuff that I
see like I don't I didn't watch it like
you name any movie from the 80s I never
saw it right anyway
you weren't allowed around screens just
kind of embedded that's not the reason
it was it was weirder than that it was
like we didn't go to the video store you
watch game shows i watch game shows I
wasn't interested in watching movies
your mom would like Rin all these movies
you'd watch them with her you watch all
types of stuff yeah I didn't want you
know I didn't watch Back to the Future
until I was an adult with my kids right
I haven't seen Top Gun I haven't seen oh
gosh let's not get you if they had to do
it but it's an advantage like you know
we're talking to somebody that I think
was Steve who direct who's directing
buddy system season 2 and he was like
you guys watched a lot of Monty Python
didn't you and I was like well I'm
familiar with it but and I take that as
a compliment but not really
but it's like and that's the it's a
great thing to like inadvertently
stumble on something that people start
to think that you were inspired by some
something great comedic Lee when the
honest truth in that instance was now he
just kind of came up with some stuff
well you know it's like it cuts both
ways because if you're a lot of writers
they're supposed to you know it's it's
prescribed by a lot of writers and
filmmakers that you should be watching
and ingesting a lot of different things
in one of the ways that that helps is
you make sure that you don't replicate
exactly you know you're not copying
anybody but you're just being inspired
by them so we actually stand a chance
kind of come in full circle of
accidentally doing exactly the same idea
because nothing is actually new no
there's no original ideas everything's
remix and so we have to rely on other
people
you know we've got first for season two
a buddy system we actually have some
writers that we're working with as
opposed to us just taking the whole
first season like we did and we trust
that they're more informed they've seen
more stuff than we have and they can be
like note that this hasn't happened yet
right no you can't do that but speak
speaking of Steve pink who's directing
the second season an incredible guy
super excited to work with him and he's
made some incredible films but in our
first meeting with him he specifically
brought up the discreet charm of the
bourgeoisie this crazy French film from
the 70s that which news flash I had not
seen and I and having seen a lot of
things I'd never even heard of it and so
I cannot pronounce or spell booze watery
yeah so he had this he was like I don't
know how this came up but no he was
talking about letting left turn choices
yeah or somebody we liked him where I
got a person comes up to the main
character in this in this movie and
they're like I have a story and they
begin to tell their story and then that
story becomes this very I don't know how
long it is but very long scene and then
the story's over and that's it and we
were like we love that idea we love that
kind of idea so we're actually doing
something similar in an episode of buddy
system and I don't want to give away the
details but we're taking something that
you might think would just be a moment a
moment
we're turning it into the entire episode
and we're doing that because of he we
didn't even see the movie he just told
us about this concept it was making a
story and moot makes it so we don't know
what the story is but the concept was
inspire inspire by the bold choice and
but if we watch the thing and then it's
like and then the specifics of that
choice we're gonna do the same thing
well then that starts to get dicey and
you know I'm not even gonna watch the
movie well we've already come up with
the whole story and what happens and
it's the most ridiculous thing we've
ever come up with by the way it I think
I think it's the dumbest thing we've
ever come up with and I'm so proud of it
yeah it's gonna be crazy
it's not gonna be easy to shoot no yeah
cuz a lot of us out door I don't know
how we're gonna do it but that's you
know what you know you're in the right
place when you when you look in front of
you and you the task seems impossible
you're like oh we must be doing the
right thing or you're about to die I
mean right then you just curse so and I
think in this instance well Steve seen
the movie well you know we can
cross-reference with him that we haven't
there's no way we could have made the
same choice no it's just so crazy but
again we've proven that it is possible
but again he's seen it we're gonna ask
him in general I think what's our
approach in terms of a summary I think
it's this is an interesting thing
because it's like when you get really
excited about something and you're
conceptualizing it when it's still very
early on
you got a google it but it's such a it's
so like throwing what's it called when
you throw water on some cold water it's
like throwing cold water on a hot and
bothered person yeah and I mean hot as
in temperature not like a good-looking
person I don't really know what your now
janitor man it's like when you're when
you're on this pulling the rug out from
under when you're on a creative catapult
and it you've just [ __ ] you just
pulled it and you're like you're flying
through there at a million miles an hour
in just a brick wall I can't write it
down quick enough you don't want to
raise a brick wall so Google I wrote has
been done yeah
so you you know it's like well you
because you want to like ride the wave
of creativity but then if that wave is
ultimately gonna crash into a baron
apocalyptic beach there's so many I
rather hit a wall ology I'd rather hit a
wall in a minute you're mixing a lot of
metaphors but I love it then hit an
apocalyptic beach in two days yeah and
we've done it all brother an other side
of the coin which is also an analogy and
the Sun burned yeah don't even get me
started you if you hang out on that
beach long enough to get a summer
because you're naked if you've got a
coin and you look at the other side of
the coin and the coin is not sunburned
it's a little bit colder because it was
under the shade you'll see the other
side of the coin yeah just trying to
ruin with your analogy here is that at
the same time we are going to continue
to be inspired sometimes sometimes I'll
just go to a magazine stand and I'll get
one of those art magazines that's like
just got weird like design things in it
not because I design anything and not
even and I'm not even particularly a
visual artist I'm much more conceptual
and let DPS and directors think about
the visual side of things but pick one
of those up
you'll pay $30 for that magazine bottom
yeah it'll be like a quarterly like art
digest and I'll just look at it just to
see what creative people are doing now
and how they're thinking about their art
and then without fail that somehow by
osmosis if I said oh look at that goes
into me and then impacts whatever we're
working on you have to get that input to
get the output that you need any not
that's not plagiarism I actually think
you're onto something when it's like you
look for inspiration in a place that
doesn't have a lot of overlap in terms
of a Venn diagram with what you're
creating so it's not like all right
we're gonna go to other buddy comedies
and look at those movies or television
shows to be inspired but it's I'm gonna
buy this graphic novel which I which I
talked about in the mythical monthly
American barbarian yeah which is it just
it rocked my world creatively I was like
gushing to you about it and
gave me the book and a graphic novel and
I read it in an afternoon
and the funny thing is is I thought it
was amazing but you liked the way you
described it built it up you much you
gave me all the spoilers so you got to
learn to just give me a little bit wet
my habits yeah I can't I can't do that
to you cuz I do it rarely most the time
you get excited about something given to
me but in this instance I think finding
inspiration maybe were where we're on to
something here that's like you find
inspiration in a sunset I don't say
unless you're a weatherman because
they're tired of them you find well then
you might just be copping the Sun set
all the time oh yeah yeah it's gotta be
something different you find inspiration
in a moving tear-jerking song unless
you're a musician I don't know this is a
working theory here you know the you
can't find too much inspiration in
something that has a has a direct
overall I think when there's a direct
overlap you're you're looking at it for
a couple of reasons and one of them is
to make sure that you're not just
replicating what somebody's doing I
don't know it's a fine line and I think
we're continuing to navigate it and
figure out figure it out as we go but
it's so much different when it comes to
something like long term like buddy
system and then when you come back to
this machine of mythical entertainment
between good mythical morning good
mythical more
this is mythical so many videos coming
out so much content in an environment
where everyone else is doing the same
thing everyone else is tapping into the
same stuff it becomes increasingly
difficult to navigate this landscape in
a way that you can actually say we're
creating something innovative and
original but that's the challenge you
got to keep you got to keep on pushing
gotta keep pushing keep pushing it man
guys let us know what you what you think
in terms of your creative process
hashtag ear biscuits if you enjoy this
conversation about this aspect of
creativity I'm sure there's other
aspects that maybe we could talk about
on subsequent episodes that's an idea
let us know hashtag ear biscuits what on
that front maybe you'd like to hear from
us we're still open to
different themes for episodes and in
general just getting your feedback and
continuing the conversation and as
always we appreciate your feedback about
ear biscuits continue to leave comments
at places where comments or you can
leave comments and ratings and places
you can leave ratings share the clips
with your friends to introduce them to
ear biscuits ELISA continue to expand
this mythical universe and just bring
more mythical beasts into the fold rip
us off if you have to we'll talk at you
next week
[Music]